este podría ser el escenario de una
novela orwelliana durante varios días en
hong kong alex tang se ha sumergido en
un mundo donde la historia se desvanece
un mundo en el que la verdad de los
hechos que no tiene valor ni importancia
el mes pasado en la televisión pública
de hong kong retiró de su página web
todos sus archivos emitidos antes de
mira estoy aquí en la página de youtube
de rt hk y del programa de hong kong
connection todas las noticias
relacionadas con los eventos de 2019 han
sido eliminadas al suprimir sus
contenidos en línea el grupo de
radiodifusión estatal está encubriendo
la memoria de los recientes movimientos
prodemocráticos en hong kong para no ver
desaparecer estos acontecimientos de la
memoria colectiva
álex y otros cientos de internautas de
hong kong empezaron a archivar los
contenidos de rtc acá antes de que
fueran eliminados definitivamente el
archivo 20 documentales en total son
unas 10 horas de contenidos
creo que es importante archivar los
porque estos reportajes son pruebas
históricas fui testigo de lo que ocurre
en hong kong en 2019 y no creo que
debamos permitir que borren la verdad
entre los documentales eliminados por el
pp-a checa
este cuenta la inacción de la policía
durante un ataque de las triadas a
manifestantes prodemocracia en 2019
por este reportaje la directora para 8 y
fue detenida y procesada por la policía
se le declara culpable de mentir para
acceder a ciertas fuentes unas condenas
sin precedentes en hong kong
a pesar de sus problemas con la ley ese
día recibió el premio al mejor
documental del año de una asociación de
periodistas estoy muy orgullosa de
representar al programa hong kong
connection y de recibir este premio
aseguró que su condena marcaba un punto
de inflexión para la libertad de prensa
en hong kong creo que a mi juicio es
sobre todo un símbolo de una represión
más grande de la libertad de prensa en
hong kong
y por supuesto podemos imaginar que la
situación no hará más que empeorar
símbolo de la toma de control de la
prensa por parte de las autoridades esta
operación a gran escala llevada a cabo
por la policía el pasado mes de agosto
contra las oficinas de apple daily un
periódico liberal muy popular y
abiertamente anti beijing un
allanamiento durante el cual el
propietario del periódico el
multimillonario y opositor al régimen
jimmy light es llevado esposado en medio
de la sala de redacción
este es el periodista que graba la
escena
cuando llegue había al menos 200
policías en la redacción lo que recuerdo
es el momento en que se llevaron a jimmy
lai a su despacho y registraron todo
durante una hora charly se unió a papel
de l hace tres años desde entonces ha
visto como los periodistas del periódico
se autocensuran el contenido de su
periódico ya no es el mismo un periódico
está hecho por varias personas y si
todos se censuran un poco al final la
información que publicamos no tendrá el
mismo sentido ahora cuando un periodista
recibe una información se censura un
poco luego pasa lo mismo con el editor
después con los correctores y a veces
con los impresores al final el contenido
del periódico ya no es el mismo
los movimientos prodemocráticos de los
últimos años han visto surgir nuevos
medios de comunicación en hong kong
publicaciones en línea financiadas
exclusivamente por los lectores
esta es la redacción de esta news somos
un medio de comunicación online de hong
kong
es tan news se dio a conocer por su
cobertura de calidad de las protestas en
2019 hoy es uno de los medios de
comunicación más serios de hong kong
exposición lo que convierte al periódico
online en un objetivo para las
autoridades
todos esperamos que nuestro periódico
sea prohibido de alguna manera en un
futuro próximo quizás nos congelen las
cuentas bancarias
quizás digan que somos una organización
ilegal
no sabemos qué excusa encontrarán
y yo personalmente siento que podrían
enviarme a la cárcel por lo que he
escrito en el pasado
la prensa de hong kong está más
amenazada que nunca en 10 años la ciudad
ha caído del puesto 34 al 80 en la
clasificación de la libertad de prensa
de reporteros sin fronteras